what would your advice be to an 18 year
old male or female that's maybe
gone through some of the same things
that you've gone through and they feel
really really alone
but they have this incredible creativity
that's inside of them
probably from a lot of the alone time
but they
want to take these feelings that they
have and instead of
doing some of the things that we hear
about that are so awful
because they feel this pain and
authorities aren't doing anything about
it teachers are blaming them and saying
you're the problem even though they're
probably not the problem
but they've grown up their entire lives
believing that they are the problem
what would you tell someone like that
has a lot of creativity and how to
channel
that's a lot um
there's a well some of these people have
reached out to me
actually some of these exact people that
you're describing
um with uh with my name is a um
because um you know what it's about you
know like it's it's
15 to 23 year old girls are really which
is not an audience i'm used to having
are really kind of latching onto this
movie even without having whether
they've
figured out a way of seeing seeing it
earlier or they haven't even seen it
and you know a lot of people have been
getting in contact with me because of it
through like facebook and stuff
and um you know it's
you know then they'll open up right away
you know some of these people i mean
one girl i don't i think she i mean i
think she was a kid like 15 or something
she sent me pictures of
her self-mutilated arm because she had
seen it wasn't my name is a but she saw
um the self-harm video that youtube band
i'm trying to remember when i told her
it was just i
i told her basically because that was
one specific that i remember because i
was really not sure how to handle it you
know i was like i don't know what to
tell this girl and
i just really told her i just opened up
about myself and what i did
and then um tried to let her know that
you know
i obviously understand you because i'm
in the exact same boat you know
and um maybe maybe sometimes it's best
not even to say that you used to be
there just say
because i currently still i'm always
kind of there so um
because if you say oh i used to be in
the same sometimes that makes people go
oh but how did you get out
you know i think in some ways it almost
might be better to tell them i feel just
like you you know like i
used to be in that place i still am and
that might sound hopeless
you know some people who don't have
these problems might think oh that
sounds hopeless but i think to the
people who do
these problems they if they see that
you're actually in the same boat
but you're you're in the same boat but
you're
channeling it in other ways um like
you're not
you know self-abusing or you're not
thinking of going and killing somebody
you know that's that's why i think and
i'm realizing this as i'm saying but
saying it but that's why i think it's
better to not say i came out of it by
doing this because a lot of people just
feel like they can't come out of it
say i understand because i'm going
through the same thing and then they go
oh
you know he's actually still dealing
with it but this is how
he's dealing with it you know i mean
i think i think that sounds more hopeful
to them and it's the truth you know
um i i'm always dealing with these um
you know these issues or they're always
in the back of my mind or whatever
um but as far as actual things that they
can do
you know you can you can if you if you
want to make a movie i mean you can um
do you have a you have a smartphone
because almost everybody even homeless
people i see have smartphones i don't
but um most people have smartphones i
have a friend
who uh shot a whole movie on a
smartphone and got an actual distributor
to put it out in stores
shoot it on your smartphone um make a
video diary
uh you know but with the subject that's
bothering you or it doesn't have to be
that but if
it could be anything you know if but if
it helps if it's your way of releasing
your issues it could be about your
issues or completely opposite you know
but if it makes you feel better about
your issues
you know make a movie about it do it on
your smartphone you might actually be
able to get it distributed or
who knows you might become the next
youtube sensation and do it like as
three minute video blogs you know um
right i just i've been thinking about
writing a book for years and i just
started writing
um a book that opens with the thing that
happened i was five that's the first
chapter i just kind of spit it out in
like 15 minutes
and um and i just started that not even
it was a
well maybe it was a week ago um because
i finally saw a book
written in a way where i thought okay
that's how i should write it because i
didn't i don't really read i watch a lot
of movies i read a lot of information i
read novels
so i finally saw a novel that was
spelled out in a way was basically
written like memories and i thought okay
that's how i should write my novel um so
even if you like if you want to write
but you don't know how maybe
look at how other people have written
because that's what happened is i just
really felt like
i can't get everything i want to say out
on film and it's sorry to get people
together so even if i get a movie made i
still missing 99 of what i want to say
how can i say everything i want to say
maybe be done with it
i should write a book but then i don't
know how to write a book you know and my
vocabulary is not even great
um but then i you know go to barnes and
noble and i started going through all
kinds of books and finally i found one
while like that's how i should write my
book and then
then it was a matter of just getting
motivated or just you know trying to
figure out how to get all your thoughts
down and finally i'm like just do it
basically just do it finally i just sat
down i put the laptop down last week
and i'm like okay just do it and i
started writing and it was easy
because it's i think it's the hardest
thing it's just
putting the first finger down you know
um
but once you start doing it just kind of
flows out even shooting
it's like sometimes i'm not motivated to
shoot but then the second i hit record i
don't want to stop
um and there's so many things or you can
volunteer if it's not a creative you
know volunteer and try and help other
uh people understand work at a homeless
shelter if you you know if it depresses
you like it can really depress me like
seeing people on the street like i
you know i'll i'm a loner but i'll go
and hang out with homeless people all
the time you know if i get a good vibe
from them and they're not
i don't think i'm gonna get you know
william i think i'm gonna get killed
because it's some kind of like uh
rush but i mean like if i get a good
vibe from homeless people i'll chat with
them for three hours you know even keanu
reeves
you could be famous and do it there's
all this stuff about keanu reeves um
you know somebody uh had been some
paparazzi was spying on him hanging out
with some homeless guy and he was there
like all day just hanging out with the
guy you know i mean
if a big celebrity can do it
you know and not worry about being seen
you know or what people think then you
can do that if that's another way of
channeling it and hopefully this all
makes sense but there's so many ways you
know volunteer if that helps
write a book if that helps um shoot on
your smartphone if you don't have a
camera it's better than
i mean i think the quality might be
better than some cameras it's better
than the cameras i used to shoot
all the amateur points or killer stuff
on any smartphone is better quality than
that
you know um there's just so many things
you can do
um and if none of that helps um
uh you know
i don't know just go somewhere and
scream until you have no breath left
i've even done that
where it's like and it comes out of
nowhere and that was something i
found recently like six months ago where
it's just like
you just start screaming and it's like
not screaming like uh you know
pointlessly i just mean you're in so
much pain that you just scream until you
have no voice left
and you actually feel relieved
afterwards because you're like you're
exhausted from it
it's kind of like cutting yourself but
better you know because you're not
harming yourself um like because cutting
yourself the problem is
and people start doing this when they
start doing that they realize it helps
because it actually
releases like natural endorphins in your
body and it actually is a natural high
so the problem with cutting yourself is
it actually does make you feel better
um so i think a good way to maybe stop
doing that is like i said the screaming
thing i found out is
it it exhausts you and that's kind of
what cutting yourself does you just kind
of feel this high afterwards and you
feel kind of feel exhausted of that
that negative energy um but now you're
harming yourself and you don't want to
do that so
screaming i think is actually and i've
seen that in a couple movies where
people are so stressed out like coming
of age movies and
somebody goes somewhere and they just
start screaming and that's when they
like finally feel better
and uh and i recently did that in real
life and i was and i've done it like
three times now and i'm like
i almost lost complete control of myself
it's like it's like you're on a drug but
that's
the point is um somehow it works
and it works for a while you don't feel
good for just five minutes like cutting
yourself you can feel good for a good
week after that
so maybe follow us fail scream scream
your
heart out you know